definitely cathartic for me some of
these parts that are dark and it stems
from all that I have oh and it
comes out and I'm like where did that
come from and then I if I really listen
to myself I know exactly where it comes
from I mean you must have had moments
playing with John Glover right that must
have been you know it must have been
funny or superficial or whatever but
then there are those moments when I'm
sure you guys looked at each other and
something Primal happens
sometimes when I had to go really
emotional and just lose my I get
lost and I and after it he would go
felt good didn't it oh yeah and I just
looked at him and I was like